giving it a little bit of detail in the
front he hasn't even done this eat your
heart out Bobby I was an art major in
college but I have never taken a formal
painting class most of the painting that
I do is digital painting and it's a
little more flat and graphic and bold
colors where you're not really like
mixing or blending I have seen some of
his videos and passing I've never
watched one of his videos in its
entirety I do love that he brings art to
the masses and at least he's like trying
to teach people the fundamentals of
painting in a way that's really
accessible I think I'll be able to
elevate a Bob Ross painting a little bit
you have to make a decision right off
today where's your horizon gonna be oh
god I did pee yellow and not like this
beautiful creamy yellow he's got now
with a clean dry brush I'm going to
begin blending this entire sky together
Oh God blending whoo okay merging down
everything that I painted and here we go
using my Photoshop knowledge we're gonna
add a Gaussian blur there we go there we
go beautiful
[Music]
let's have a little footy Hill back here
in the distance somewhere and all I'm
gonna do just take this brush and tap
[Music]
let's try and do a paint brush let's see
oh that's not the move that's not the
move at all we have to make another big
decision maybe there's another plane or
[Music]
I'm losing my ability to be quick be
because of now I'm like actually trying
[Music]
maybe there's a little clump of trees
live right in here
[Music]
yeah there we go
that looks cute okay let's do this entry
maybe there's a happy little evergreen
tree who lives right there
we don't have anything but happy trees
just work back and forth
I see how this dark color shows up
against that light oh yeah that's
exactly what I wanted to happen perfect
actually like I'm not gonna lie I'm
learning some things from him today
[Music]
let's do a big evergreen tree on the
other side I'm doing another tree I'm
just gonna call bull on a little bit of
this because the Sun is setting behind
him but the trees getting lit from this
side there's an imaginary Sun somewhere
in this equation you will sign this way
sincerely hope you've enjoyed it I look
forward to see you again next time we're
gonna sign it in a very garish color
down in the bottom corner just so people
know it's me I don't normally paint
landscapes and I would not call myself
the most gifted landscape painter but he
empowers you to make you feel like you
can
[Music]
you